-♪♪ Hold my gaze ♪♪
-All right, here's how it works.
We're going to take turns
picking up a card
and reading a sentence
that we've never seen before.
-Okay.
-As soon as you read
the sentence, you must say,
"Hold my gaze,"
and we will maintain
unblinking eye contact.
Now, if you laugh you lose.
This is going to be -- This
going to be tough for me, okay.
-Okay, well --
-Since you're my guest --
-We'll see how this goes.
-You'll be going first.
Go ahead and take a card.
-Okay.
-And then when you're ready,
just read it to me and then say,
"Hold my gaze."
-Oh, man.
-[ Clears throat ]
-You know, when I put my pants
on this morning,
the drier hadn't gotten them
completely dry yet.
They're -- They're still damp.
I like it that way.
Hold my gaze.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't -- I can't, though.
-Okay, go.
-I like them that way.
-I can't do that.
-Okay, here we go, my turn.
-Yeah.
-Here we go.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
I -- I don't remember
where I parked my car.
Oh, I remember now.
I parked it in Europe.
Please, hold my gaze.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Chuckling ] I'm the worst.
I'm laughing at myself.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am the worst.
All right.
-You can do this.
You can do this.
-This one I'm not doing.
-Okay.
-I'm not going to smile.
I won't break.
-All right, all right.
-Whew. I can't look at you.
[ Laughter ]
-My favorite "Game of Thrones"
episode was the one where --
[ Chuckles ]
where Steve got hit
by a school bus.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, do hold my gaze.
♪♪♪♪
-It was the episode where Steve
got hit by a school bus?
-The very best.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was your favorite --
I don't think you were watching
"Game of Thrones."
All right, for our final round,
this time I will read a category
and we'll have to name
as many things in that category
as we can...
-Uh-huh.
-...while saying, "hold my gaze"
after each one.
-Okay, cool.
[ Laughter ]
I hope I know
what the category is.
-Here we go.
We're about to find out.
-I don't know a lot of stuff.
-Ready?
-Okay, let's go.
-Here we go.
You go first. Types of bagels.
♪♪♪♪
-Onion. Hold my gaze.
-Egg.
[ Laughter ]
Hold my gaze.
-Everythang.
[ Laughter ]
Hold my gaze.
-Sesame.
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Sesami!"
Kate McKinnon, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All episodes
of "Heads Will Roll"
are available Thursday
on Audible.